[Music]
[Applause]
okay we posted this yesterday and we
gave a heads up to eddie werder and to
eddie eddie werder he told me i could
call him eddie years ago i don't believe
that for a second totally made that up
okay peter schrager later okay here's a
question i posted on the twitters
yesterday okay you can start your nfl
team with any three defensive players
all the time any combo of positions it
doesn't have to be you know
the players you pick stay healthy for
their entire career and they're not on
one team yeah anybody anybody any era
any player any position but you get
three and my picks were reggie white
lawrence taylor and ed reed and i got
pretty good props for that okay a lot of
people picked deion sanders as their
defensible right and we got lots of
responses well you can't go wrong with
reggie white and lawrence taylor those
are unimpeachable especially if lawrence
taylor's going to stay healthy that's
true that's true well ed werder covered
deion sanders ed joins us now uh your
three defensive players all time you get
them for their entire careers and
they're healthy
yeah i'm gonna take the obvious two and
say lawrence taylor reggie white and i'm
gonna go
i thought about ed reed i thought about
dion sanders but i'm going to take
charles woodson
because he could play corner and safety
and in addition to intercepting passes
he rushed the quarterback and got sacks
at an unusually high rate for a
defensive back okay
how great was dion
dion was great i mean he was he could
play offense defense he returned the
ball on special teams he was a
unusual because he was a defensive
player with offensive instincts when he
got the ball in his hand
and
i mean you talked to guys like you know
troy aikman who played with him and
against him he was legitimately a guy
who created the question in the mind of
a quarterback as to whether you were
willing to challenge him on that side of
the field and the funniest thing i
remember about dion was kind of toward
the end
of his career in dallas there was a game
on a sunday where peyton manning and the
colts and marvin harrison they threw at
him an inordinate number of times like
10 times
and i i had a previously scheduled
sit-down with dion uh that next week and
so i asked him about this and he said
man i ain't worried i've been out there
on that island longer than gilligan
any any laughed as you could imagine and
so did i and as i was leaving the room a
few minutes later having finished the
interview he said oh man and i'm like i
said what he said
i want to save that line for the
playoffs
he was already thinking of what lines
you wanted to use at the super bowl week
is aaron donald encroaching on reggie
white territory here
yeah i mean absolutely i think he's the
most dominant defensive player in the
league right now and has been for you
know almost his entire career so without
question he's the most feared defensive
player in the nfl right now but yeah
that's a great point but you know i
really think of guys who are currently
playing and i eliminated all the guys
that i never saw myself so
you know deacon jones and guys like that
i love knight train lane those guys who
might have merited consideration from a
slightly older person of which there are
not many anymore
when we look at players now though with
terrell davis getting in and being
injured and having a six-year career can
you be a hall of famer after four years
five years
i've never been a hall of fame voter so
i don't really know what the cutoff is
but i know that's a major consideration
his longevity of career although they've
certainly made concessions not only for
players but even coaches you know
recently that was one of the arguments
against jimmy johnson was that he didn't
coach long enough to uh to bear it i
thought it was a ridiculous argument in
his case and i think it for the most
part longevity matters unless a player
was just incredibly dominant um and and
that led to championship performances
where otherwise they would not have
existed so i think that's why jimmy
johnson and terrell davis get exceptions
but if you like aaron donald
you win three defensive players of the
year in let's say a five-year period or
jj watt wins three like is is that
enough where
the voters are going to go that's an mvp
they're uh that that's a whole of five
i don't think i don't think those guys
are gonna have to win super bowls like
most players would have to do
because of the the reason you decided i
mean to dominate at your position
on a team that wasn't good enough to get
to a championship i think says an awful
lot about those players too
the biggest question in dallas today is
what
well
for a time
how are they going to rebound from this
um this was an epic disaster even by
their standards jerry jones acknowledged
as much you know after the game saying
that
um
he couldn't remember being more
disappointed that he didn't see this
coming that when you have this
collection of talent you have to win
um and they didn't uh not only i mean
this used to be a team that couldn't get
to the nfc championship game couldn't
get out of the divisional round and this
team wins 12 games has a home game and
can't even get out of the wild card
round
they were dominated at home only team to
lose at home
in wild card weekend super wild card
weekend
uh was the cowboys
well you tweeted this out that you know
the cowboys win total and point total
was inflated by playing against bad
teams in their own division and this
caught up with them that you almost
start to believe hey
we can go out there and put 50 points
hey we got two defensive players who are
impactful players
well were they impactful when they were
playing against substandard teams and
that offense was it good against
substandard teams
and i think we found out what the answer
is here
you know back in the 90s when the
cowboys were a dominant team if you
looked at the nfc east i mean you had
joe gibbs coaching had you know bill
parcells coaching lawrence taylor phil
sims you know any number of great
players you know daryl
um
why can't i think of his name all of a
sudden daryl green um reggie white all
those guys were in that division and so
when you made it through that that meant
something like you were ready for
anything at that point in the playoffs
and this team went 6-0 against the nfc
east the only team in the league that
went undefeated in its division the
point differential in those games the
cowboys were plus 133
they were six and six including playoffs
against non-division opponents not only
not only teams that weren't as good but
teams that they didn't know as well and
the point differential was just 33 plus
33 in way more games yeah so
and if you look at it you know they
at the end of the season mccarthy talked
about you know playing the way they did
and trying to create momentum and and uh
offensive confidence in that final game
against the eagles while the eagles sat
out like 16 starters you know the
cowboys scored 51 points and they were
rolling into the playoffs and feel but
you know look at what happened to they
they scored 43 at the time of season
high against atlanta went outside the
division lost them next week they scored
56 against washington
uh that was their new high went outside
the division lost the next week and then
they scored 51 against the eagles went
outside the division of the playoffs and
lost
so yeah i think they got an inflated
sense of self and they weren't nearly
the dominant team that the division made
them appear to be
and then you have the coaching situation
here i know that jerry jones i guess has
said that mike mccarthy is coming back
you're the two coaches you want to keep
you're probably going to lose at least
one of them and dan quinn and kellen
moore but you're going to keep mike
mccarthy um
do you think that that's how this plays
out you lose both coordinators or just
dan quinn
well
it was interesting that right after the
game when jerry jones came out of the
losing locker room a place he never
expected to be on this particular sunday
he did walk over to us and i asked him
directly about whether he would consider
a coaching change under the
circumstances and i fully expected him
to flatly shut it down and he didn't he
said something to the effect that i
don't even want to address oh so you
asked that question
you know because i when i heard it i was
like man it's really easy
if you ask any owner of a playoff team
right now
would they give you a i don't know i
don't want to address that right now
now granted most owners don't do
interviews but right it it felt like it
was
hey i can rubber stamp this and move on
and now he kind of left it in the ether
there a little bit
well and and let's put it in context you
know jerry jones has been doing this for
30 years and the first coach he fired
was tom landry
um and he's either hired or fired or
bought out every coach they've ever had
in the history of the franchise so he
knows the gravity of the question
especially
in the circumstances we're talking about
this horrific loss that they've just
suffered which he fully
admits and and he goes on after that
answer
to basically say like i told you like we
had this incredible collection of talent
in other words i as the general manager
and we as a front office we gave mike
mccarthy this incredibly talented team
and he trained wrecked at the first
opportunity in the postseason so yeah i
think jerry knew what he was saying and
now whether they thought about that
possibility oh you know for a few hours
overnight
i don't know i don't know if you just
wanted to make mccarthy feel
uncomfortable that he wouldn't give him
an endorsement in that moment
but and he still really hasn't said yet
that he's coming back it was stephen
jones who said it yesterday that he
absolutely expected mccarthy back and my
understanding is mccarthy's going to
speak to the media this afternoon uh out
of the star and i'll be there for that
um unless something i say on this show
prevents that from happening but
but um but i i guess i yeah it was i
think the question uh becomes more
legitimate and timely because of what
you said the circumstances of hey kellen
moore's interviewing with the broncos
yesterday he's interviewing with the
vikings and the dolphins this week you
know dan quinn is probably going to get
three or four offers
and do you want to lose this guy as a
defensive coordinator who took the worst
defense in franchise history and in one
year turned it into a great asset that
actually outplayed your offense most of
the season so but i think since he
hasn't prevented dan quinn from
interviewing i'm assuming he's decided
he's going to keep mike mccarthy and let
dan quinn go if he has to he's ed werder
he covers the nfl for the mothership
also covers the cowboys of course you
know you start to look at the end of
that game i thought that that
kind of washed away the sins of mccarthy
and dak prescott in that game
that dak didn't have a good game and now
it feels like the refs did this to us
and and you know that
dak didn't do this too you didn't do
anything for the first three quarters
right and time management clock
management with mike mccarthy we've seen
it before we shouldn't be surprised at
any of this
you know i didn't buy the excuse of hey
we practiced this well if you practice
it you didn't practice
this correctly
and it just felt like we're letting dak
prescott off the hook a little bit that
that was a poor performance
well uh obviously i think there were a
lot of games where what we saw the other
day played itself out happened in the
denver loss at home it happened in the
raider loss at home uh and it happened
again against the 49ers which is for
three quarters the offense does nothing
and then there's this frantic effort to
get back in the game with some level of
success but in none of those games do
they ever retake the lead this was a
team that never came from behind all
season long
but i don't think it was entirely dak
prescott's fault do i think dak in his
first year back from this catastrophic
injury he suffered last year was the
same player no i don't think he was uh
he was not the dual threat that he was
before that injury against the giants
last year but i think the the the most
significant problem they have is their
offensive line and their inability to
create a running game
and you know i mean ezekiel elliott had
one yard averaged one yard per rush the
other day against the 49ers before first
contact which is the worst uh in four
career playoff games for zeke and
um even though they played half the game
and nick boso wasn't out there rushing
the passer
with a four-man rush dak got pressured
20 times and sacked five times i think
the biggest question about this offense
is how come there were so few times when
dak got the ball in the shotgun or got
to the top of his drop and let it go
because his guy his first breed or his
second read was open where were those
throws it was constantly him holding the
ball deep into the progression pressure
starting to come and then dump it off
somewhere uh why isn't cd lamb a bigger
factor why isn't tony pollard used
differently i mean to me those are the
bigger questions then hey how come dak
prescott can't win a playoff game like
this dak did have an apology and as soon
as i heard the words i was like oh he's
going to walk those words back where he
basically was you know saying
complimenting the uh the crowd the
family condoned right he condoned it
yeah throwing debris at the officials uh
but
i guess he issued a statement yesterday
he did the the interesting thing was
when when he said it
um
he thought initially that people were
talking about he didn't see it happen
and so when it was described to him and
he was asked about it in his post-game
news conference he thought people were
throwing trash at demarcus lawrence and
other players because some of them uh
were hit with some of the debris
um and then when somebody so he answered
the question any and he criticized that
behavior but then when it was made clear
to him that it was the officials who
were the target he said you know
something like well credit to them then
you know kind of a thing um and endorse
that and i think one it was out of
character for dak to say that
uh i think i think he meant what he said
in terms of his apology uh i think it
was sincere
and he regrets it now whether there's
fallout for that for the cowboys next
year as you know how games are called
early in the season that remains to be
seen but one of the things that happened
to this team late in the year was
i believe it probably was mike mccarthy
who basically
gave the players
um the excuse for losing that the
officials were against them like they
were always trying to beat the opposing
team and this third element the
officials and the reality is
they were the most penalized team in the
nfl all regular season they're the only
team in the nfl dan that had two games
where they were assessed
14 penalties the only team or only four
such games in the holy they had half of
them
and so for them to be arguing are there
missed calls always against both teams
in every game
but the fact that they're claiming that
the officials are biased against them to
the point that it's detrimental and
actually causes them to lose it's
preposterous
and now that the cowboys are out of the
playoffs what are you gonna do what are
you covering now oh there's there's
plenty more uh cowboys
funerals to eulogize
um for me to officiate
uh i don't know normally normally i go
on and cover more playoff games and and
put them aside but in this case i think
there's a little more interest in
continuing to examine why this happened
even though you can argue
same outcome they've had for 26
consecutive seasons
they don't get to a championship game
how many playoff wins have you covered
for the cowboys
a lot because i covered the 90s teams oh
okay okay so i covered all i covered the
three super bowl wins i covered the loss
in the championship game under switzer
to the 49ers
the uh i guess there have been three or
four since you could say since aikman's
retirement how many of you covered i
would say there's what aikman's or romo
1-1 dax 1-1
that's
it there was no social media the last
time they won there was no internet the
last time they won the super bowl right
it was a better world oh it was it was
oh
safe travels ed thank you as always
great to hear from you buddy thanks for
the invite dan that's ed werder espn nfl
reporter and of course he uh covers the
cowboys